la baja participación en esta octava
jornada Nacional de protestas contra la
reforma de pensiones pudiera ser una
muestra de la fractura que existe ya en
el poder de convocatoria de los
sindicatos para traer personas a las
calles era de esperar si tenemos en
cuenta que han pasado Ya dos meses desde
el inicio de este movimiento además que
le cuesta a las personas dejar el
trabajo para venir a protestar y también
que no se ha logrado nada porque el
gobierno continúa con esta iniciativa
con su reforma para modificar las
jubilaciones en el país por si fueran
pocas las decepciones pues la asamblea
nacional esa comisión mixta paritaria de
siete senadores y siete asambleístas se
puso de acuerdo en el texto final que
será votado mañana primero por el senado
y luego por la asamblea nacional de
Catorce votos diez estuvieron a favor y
cuatro en contra eso significa que la
mayoría presidencial obtuvo apoyo de la
derecha y si esto se manifestara también
mañana en la asamblea nacional porque el
senado
podríamos decir que tiene luz verde allí
El Ejecutivo pues estaríamos en
presencia probablemente ya del fin de
esta saga al menos desde el punto de
vista parlamentario importante señalar
que si no fuera así y el gobierno de
Elizabeth guarne decidiera aprobar a la
fuerza este proyecto de ley a través del
artículo 49.3 de la Constitución varios
sindicatos sobre todo del sur de Francia
han expresado que no habrá reglas para
las manifestaciones dejando entrever que
Podrían haber manifestaciones violentas
en las calles hay que ver qué sucede
mañana en la asamblea nacional pero por
el momento ya se vislumbra el fin de
esta crisis en Francia